we have to wait and see what the numbers
are coming very shortly I think but all
the indications are that the government
has completely lost control of our
immigration system and what they fail to
do is build opportunities for local
Workforce Development and skills and
talent and career planning and as a
result of that employers are having to
reach for bringing overseas migrant
labor into the country and I think this
is about balance of course we need
immigration in our country but we need
to balance that against maximizing
opportunities for local people but we've
got seven million people on NHS waiting
lists 2.5 million people on long-term
sick the government has slashed the
further education budget the
apprenticeship Levy simply isn't working
so we need reforms in our labor market
and as those reforms kick in you would
see a decrease in inward migration so
give me figures what uh what would be an
opportunity for the labor I'm actually
not going to give you a specific number
because if we look at things like the
you know Putin's illegal invasion of
Ukraine the authoritarian Crackdown in
Hong Kong we rightly as a country
welcomed large numbers of ukrainians and
Hong kongers as a result of that if you
put numbers in place you're making
yourself a hostage to Fortune so we
don't think you need to have specific
numbers but what you need to have is a
clear commitment to getting these
numbers as they are down they are too
high and they're too high for the
reasons that I've just set out so over
what time frame then would you get those
figures done well I think a lot of it
could happen rapidly for example we've
put forward a proposal to scrap the 20
discount that is you're able to do on
shortage occupation lists which in fact
enables employers to undercut and to pay
lower wages what that does is that means
lower wages to people who are migrants
yeah and the you you then get a
situation where the job becomes less
attractive to to local people less
people local people apply for it and you
just perpetuate the problem and
perpetuate the situation so it's about
it's we're scrapping that that was a
policy that was announced by kirstama
and Yvette Cooper yesterday and it's
absolutely the right thing to do because
we don't believe that two people doing
the same job should be paid a different
wage for doing it and it's also about
incentivizing making jobs more
attractive making career opportunities
more attractive is how you're going to
get more local people applying for those
jobs and therefore that would put
downward pressure on the number of
people coming into the country from
overseas what criteria would you use in
order for people to like Ukraine Hong
Kong Syria to come into the country
because we had a gentleman sat there in
the last hour representing the Sudanese
community and he wants people from Sudan
to be able to come into the UK well the
refugee convention is clear that if
you're fleeing violence persecution you
should have the right to come and um
Island yes and that's right but of
course we have to balance that against
the pressure on our own public services
and resources what we first of all need
to do is a government that's actually
got a grip of the Asylum backlog 166
000 Asylum seekers in that backlog a
number that has exploded over recent
years that's the biggest part of this
problem because you've got people in
limbo not getting their claims reviewed
those who are unsuccessful should be
removed from the country those that are
successful should be given leave to
remain that gives them the right to work
and to get on with their lives gets them
out of hotels which are costing six
million pounds a day so I think we need
a a policy on Asylum which is based on
hard graft and Common Sense and quiet
diplomacy rather than all the headline
chasing and government by gimmick that
we see we've seen over the last 13 years
so you're saying you would allow
Sudanese
there are many many Sudanese who come
here and claim Asylum I think Sudanese
Sudan is one of the countries that has
over 80 percent uh success rate in
Asylum claims but it one of the key
things here is to Fast Track claims that
are based on family reunion so people
who are in Sudan who have family in the
UK that's something that should be
prioritized and decisions should be made
more quickly okay uh what would care
stammer do about stopping the boats
so our five-point plan is to scrap the
unworkable unethical and unaffordable
Rwanda plan and use that money that's
being wasted now to boost up the
National Crime agency and to get much
better working with frontex and into
Poland europol to crack down and break
the model of the people Smugglers clear
the backlog as I already set out we
would upgrade the seniority of
caseworkers and decision makers in the
home office to get that backlog cleared
which of course the government says
they're doing well there's very little
evidence that that's working because
they haven't recruited anything like the
numbers that they needed to recruit of
course the government's panicking right
they've finally woken up to the fact
that they've messed up in a big way on
this whole issue and it's too little too
late so we of course we we will need in
our first hundred days as a labor
government this is going to be a top
priority in terms of getting a grip on
this backlog and working on it to get
the right people in place we also need a
returns deal with the European Union so
I think most people would accept that
the Tories some of those are in place
including Albania yeah I mean there's a
broader need for a replacement to the
Dublin convention so when Boris Johnson
negotiated his botched brexit deal he
failed to negotiate a successor to the
Dublin convention which enabled us to
return Asylum Seekers to Safe third
countries including to the European
union we need to get that returns deal
in place but we know that that needs to
be on the basis of a give and take
Arrangement between the United Kingdom
and the EU which should be based on us
of getting safe and legal routes working
so that there's a quid pro quo between
ourselves and the European Union that's
what a mature grown-up relationship
based on negotiation with the EU rather
than antagonism and burning all our
bridges which is I'm afraid what the
conservatives have been doing for the
last few years Tina Turner fan massive
Tina Turner fan
um I think what's Love's got to do with
what's Love's got to do with it I think
is an amazing song and I I it's such
tragic news about what's happened I've
been sort of singing Tina Turner songs
in my head all morning even before I
came on this show okay okay Mario was
sat there in the last hour she sang
What's Love Got to Do with it I'm not
going to be doing that because I don't
think that'll be a vote winner
I've done karaoke a few with a few of my
colleagues if you got them in here and
asked them they say no I don't think
kinnick should be doing anything yeah a
bit like me couldn't carry a tune in a
bucket yes for you as always regards to
your parents thank you very much